E aí
[Música]
Olá você sabia que o Brasil é um dos
maiores produtores de conhecimento
científico no mundo é nós ocupamos a 13ª
posição porém o nosso indice de
desenvolvimento humano O que é uma média
de expectativa de anos de estudo anos de
vida e a renda bruta percata nós
ocupamos a posição 79ª esse fato mostra
um grande descompasso entre o que a
gente produz EA qualidade de vida da
nossa população fica então seguinte
questionamento Por que que a gente
produz não dialoga com a qualidade de
vida da nossa sociedade importa que
lembrar que nós somos uma sociedade
maioria alto declarada Negra e que a
universidade o lugar onde se produz a
maior parte do conhecimento científico
no nosso país e monocromática e branca
de acordo com estudo de Tavares estudos
do ano de 2015 que mapearam a
distribuição de bolsas de pesquisa no
nosso país negros e negras e tem uma
taxa muito pequena de bolsistas
de aproximadamente trinta por cento do
total de bolsistas de iniciação
científica o início da carreira em 2015
no topo da carreira na bolsa de
produtividade em pesquisa a participação
de negros e negras é muito pequena
quando sai da iniciação passa por
mestrado e doutorado vai se afunilando
até ficar muito pequeno no topo da
carreira isso gera um impacto por
exemplo eu desconheço qualquer mulher
negra brasileira viva ou morta cujo nome
esteja associado a uma intervenção
cultural científica ou em qualquer outra
área da esfera social e que seja
celebrada como tal por sua vez no mesmo
ano no ano de 2015 de um total de 4040
bolsistas somente 4.993 eram mulheres
tem um relatório da Unesco de do ano de
2017 que diz que as adolescentes não
buscam as carreiras de ciências virgem
estudos técnicos e tecnológicos na mesma
pro
e os adolescentes nós somos a maioria em
áreas ligadas ao cuidado cerca de
sessenta por cento nas áreas de saúde
humana linguística letras e artes e
somos só trinta por cento nas áreas de
ciências exatas da terra engenharias e
computação nós somos um time de
professoras enfermeiras assistentes
sociais e psicólogas Mas porquê que isso
acontece por uma questão cultural as
mulheres costumam escolher por opções
mais próximas de como foram educadas e
assim mais próximas ao cuidado mais são
também essas profissões que tratam da
manutenção e preservação da vida que não
por acaso são as menos valorizadas e
portanto mal pagas refletindo o retrato
da invisibilidade feminina no mercado de
trabalho eu tenho explicação provável
para isso uma provável participação
menor de mulheres nessas áreas também a
persistência de exterior
a educação o que implica que papéis
definidos para o feminino tal como mãe
responsável pelos afazeres domésticos e
também pelo cuidado da família não vão
se conciliar com uma carreira científica
logo atividade científica vai ser
considerada inadequada para as meninas
pela dificuldade da gente compatibilizar
o exercício profissional com a vida
familiar contudo a ciência
empreendimento humano e é desenvolvida
por homens e por mulheres cientistas só
que essas mulheres esses homens
participam de uma sociedade que possui o
viés masculino e branco dessa forma
visões deturpadas deficiência refletem
na construção de conhecimento científico
e na manutenção de uma visão deformada
de ciência como neutra e Masculino a
gente ainda Precisa considerar outra
coisa que o contexto de produção do
conhecimento é o da meritocracia isso
vai sempre Celebrar competência com
positividade com
o texto tem que mostrar de extremamente
eficaz uma vez que não tem produzido
respostas aos problemas sociais do mundo
a ciência Mundial Então ela é ensinada e
produzida a partir de contextos do
acidente que prometem uma visão neutra e
também privilegiada e que seguem
ignorando as demandas políticas as
desigualdades de raça e gênero que foram
construídas nas própria história da
humanidade dessa forma as representações
sobre ciências são geralmente formadas
pela imagem de um homem branco e também
europeu o que nós conhecemos consciência
foi assim estabelecido pela invenção da
modernidade por sua vez a modernidade é
sinônimo de racismo e colonização a
gente vive numa sociedade tecnológica e
tecnologia é fruto do desenvolvimento do
conhecimento científico assim esse
conhecimento segue sendo o status de
verdade pô
e a ciência moderna ela se constrói na
lógica binária de dominação ou se é
verdade ou se é mentira ou é moderno ou
é selvagem ou é branco ou é preto ou é
bom ou é mau ou é homem ou é mulher ou é
certo ou errado Manda aí uma solidez a
lógica do ou ou você é uma coisa ou
então é essencialmente outra essa lógica
segue desqualificando tudo que se
encontra na sua posição e geram reflexo
Pergunte a qualquer criança da escola
básica que cientista ela conhece e essa
disputa de narrativa será vencida pelo
sujeito Universal ou seja se cristaliza
lugares de alocação pré-estabelecidos
é ou eu sou negra te vista ou eu sou
cientista é óbvio que meu corpo chega
primeiro Mas é possível e necessário
considerar que eu sou uma mulher negra e
também militante e também sou mãe e
também sou cientista e também sou
pesquisadora e assim eu o senhor me
julga lógica do ou para construir a
lógica doer uma lógica plural que segue
contrariando dogmas Hoje eu tô aqui
discutindo com vocês sobre diversidade
nas Ciências porque ela não existe se
ela existisse certamente eu estaria só
discutindo sobre ciências ou talvez
sobre a minha produção e é justo por
isso que eu criei uma linha de pesquisa
que vira Visa convocar preferencialmente
mulheres negras militantes estudantis e
cientistas analisaram suas próprias
histórias de maneira crítica discutindo
a construção da subalternidade e
utilizando as temáticas de suas
pesquisas ou modernas
a paz para o ensino de conceitos de
ciências tudo isso tem um objetivo de
incentivar meninas sobretudo as meninas
negras que escolheu as carreiras de
Ciências e Tecnologias a exceção da
diversidade na produção de modelos que
respondam às questões urgentes da
humanidade impactam sempre positivamente
o desenvolvimento do conhecimento e
também da própria tecnologia Por que vão
agregar perfis mais dinâmicos e
abrangente de se pensar em produzir
soluções isso impacta não só os negócios
mas sobretudo gera dinheiro no final das
contas eu gostaria de considerar que é
uma gente a inserção de outros sujeitos
além do homem branco europeu na produção
e no final de ciências por uma questão
de justiça social Pois todas as pessoas
devem ter igualdade de oportunidade
também de Justiça Econômica os silêncios
e mulheres não tiverem as mesmas
oportunidades que o sujeito Universal o
nosso país tá retirando desse ato
uma das minhas criativas expropriando
suas capacidades laborativas e por
razões sociais uma vez que mulheres e
negros precisam usufruir de uma boa
educação científica fato é que a
diversidade em ciências traz
perspectivas mas também valores
motivações métodos de trabalho distintos
para o trabalho científico permitindo
produzir melhores respostas para a
sociedade como um todo sobretudo nesse
momento difícil em que vivemos o
contexto de uma pandemia é a ciência que
promete ser o diferencial na disputa de
narrativas são as carreiras Steam que
são aquelas que englobam ciências
tecnologias e engenharia sa se
matemáticas que vivem nesse momento uma
revisão de suas Produções EA diversidade
tem sido tratada como um fator que vai
trazer inovações narrativas e ensino
dessas profissões é preciso incluir a
diversidade sobretudo a presença de né
é de mulheres nesses setores para que a
gente possa promover a Equidade racial
na Ciência e Tecnologia remover
obstáculos para essas carreiras tornar a
ciência receptiva Nossa a necessidade de
enfrentar a sociedade as questões éticas
dessa como um todo Ter um melhor
relacionamento com os conhecimentos
tradicionais com os nossos conhecimentos
não cês traz para que os conhecimento
científico possa de fato produzir
respostas mais robustas por exemplo a
bateia ela é um instrumento utilizado
até hoje na mineração é um tipo de
peneira né E foi trazida para cá pelos
nossos ancestrais africanos escravizados
continua até hoje sendo um instrumento
indispensável nas minerações do nosso
país é uma tecnologia ancestral e a
gente precisa conversar sobre isso mas
você deve estar se perguntando nesse
momento eu não sou uma pessoa negra não
sou da ciência e nem sua mulher como é
que ele tinha impacta o mo
Oi gente tem uma máxima que a técnica do
pescoço do seu ambiente de trabalho
lazer educação e atuação como tudo você
vai virar seu pescoço por um lado para o
outro para frente para trás e vai tentar
responder à seguinte questão você está
entre pessoas iguais se a sua resposta
for sim é preciso pensar por que que a
dimensão da diversidade está ausente dos
seus ambientes Olha o racismo é um lugar
de produção de ausências e de fato a
Inovação vai se fortalecer com a
diversidade girando nada mais nada menos
que melhores condições da produção da
nossa própria vida